the gyro can experience what Henry's
done for 25 135 201 55 and 170 I mean I
don't know any manager that's ever had
that many champions in the stable I
think Henry a year and a half from now
is like hmm it's business yeah he wants
big money you know that look he's one of
the absolutely undeniably the greatest
loves the fight like their technique is
just so fun to watch so fast
I mean Henry's a special guy he really
is I mean you look at incredible athlete
won the gold medal in Olympics one two
division and then he's winning by
stoppages against world-class smashing
PK yeah he's amazing he really is
amazing
but I I respect his choice I mean the
guy decides to go out on top and will go
down in history as one of the Great's of
all or not ever shore on the UFC is
probably you know as athletes the
hardest people to do business with in
the world so when you do have the cards
in your hand you have to go to war for
yourself yes no other time will you be
able to but the only time he's gonna
have those cards is when he's actually
the champion right now he is the
champion if he decides to vacate the
title like he has they remove him from
the rank and they put it'll just get why
they don't just give it back
I believe that well he can earn it he
doesn't have no problem doing a fight
he'll get it outside immediately right
but you won't begin to not be the
champion going into the fight so there's
like financial considerations but that
was I believe that was him playing his
cards right going to war you know and
they and they they don't respect you
enough and so eventually have to at what
point do you say no right I think
legitimately he's probably done too
when you stop and think about the fact
that he retired from wrestling at 21 you
know not even at the peak of his powers
right well after he wins a gold medal
and then the fact that he came back from
that first round stoppage to deejay and
then beats him in the rematch like what
was it like three years later and with
his knees his knee and his ankle always
looking like he goes out like with that
with the mauryas fight and in that
deejay fight just so crazy overcoming
that and just kidding yeah nothing left
to accomplish the Marlin murasa fight
was incredible
montfort mom she's so talented [ __ ]
good man and so so nasty with his kicks
it was crazy yeah there's like taking an
ass-kicking for a route that it overcome
that like you and then a second round
just ban himself too stressed and some
expansion he's a very intelligent person
yeah but retiring like that it surely
just go out like no one's done it like
that like George's done him but he had a
rough flight prior to it he came back
later like to thinking is this no one's
done it I always say do things outside
the box be remembered I think you'll
find you he mayor Emanuel captain Eric
think she's gonna fight I think but I do
think it'll be on his terms which is
ultimately all he's fighting for right
yeah yeah well listen man the guy he's
done amazing stuff
[Applause]